so while the media hopes to unseat a
president they despise here's what's
happening around the world Chinese
President Xi Jinping just announced this
country with significantly lower tariffs
on vehicle imports now maybe he's
responding to president Trump's
complaints over unfair trade practices
it's a signal tore to compromise after
Trump made a huge stink about it so
what's next after this huge stink a sigh
of relief which sounds familiar
there's only months ago that the media
claimed nuclear war with North Korea was
certain
but then that chaos gave way to calm
remember all the noise before the tax
cuts it evaporated as bonuses flowed
people screamed about the apocalypse
after we ditched the Paris Accords where
did all that fear go
same thing with TPP so are you sensing a
pattern Trump kicks up the conflict to
set a table for negotiation and what you
end up with is progress it's very old
school so old in fact reporters under 40
don't know what it is where is the
paralysis of analysis that were so used
to China reducing tariffs North Korea
talking about denuclearization ice is
gone for now I hope forever what does
this tell us after eight years of the
floundering inept new school it's an old
school dude in his 70s getting crap done
and if you don't get it maybe it's cuz
you've never seen it before in your
adult lifetime enjoy it while it lasts
all right let's go around the horn we
got 37 seconds am i right or wrong
Kimberly yes no or 12 pains me to say so
I do believe that's your head on your
body that is my body yes I'm not doing
anything illegal Thank You China need to
access a u.s. technology this is
something I believe that China is making
a concession towards the United States
because they know that mmm Donald Trump
is somebody who is a different kind of
breed this is a disruptor this is
someone that's willing to take risk this
is a businessman that's in the Oval
Office and he is going to say we we need
to even the playing field out and not
make this so imbalance and unjust in
terms of the United States relationship
with China as it relates to tariffs and
whatnot so I think this is a step in the
pot in the right direction that the
United States is going and China and
hopefully this is going to smooth
a little bit more be a little more even
multiple-choice Dana a b b a c bananas i
agree on almost everything except for
the tariff part yeah these tariffs that
trying to announce they had already been
a part of the equation and i think she
has played this very well because
president Trump is complaining about
this meantime what we really are asking
them for is to stop subsidizing their
high-tech industry China's not budged on
that at all the China goes back out and
says oh by the way we'll do these
vehicle things and then we all say oh
that's amazing okay great they're like
she's like oh yeah well I already
announced about it and III think that
the tariff thing is actually probably
going to work itself out fine in the
long run but this one I don't think is
the big win Jesse did Dana completely
agree with me totally agree with me or
absolutely agree with me I think they've
made a lot of promises but we actually
have to see what they're really going to
do about it with that said this is the
second time this has happened with the
tariffs he promised to slap tariffs on
South Korea and then all of a sudden
they caved and opened up their car
markets and said they'd decrease their
steel exports to us by 30% and the way
he's doing this he's monetizing our
security relationships he's doing this
with the European Union and NATO he's
doing this with South Korea because of
the North Korean crisis it's a whole new
way of doing things hopefully it keeps
moving this dress we have more leverage
than we even think and they need to open
up their markets and they should to US
companies and technique meet our
technology and it's real actual property
final question to watch should you say
one more thing is up next
but I think it's important to understand
that president G said that he was going
to do the tariffs lifts no one's happy
but I'm happy I think the people who are
most upset by this are people like
farmers out in Iowa and Nebraska voted
for Trump say oh my god all of a sudden
our value our crops are less valuable
under Trump and we you know a lot of
people voted for Trump well you got what
you're voted for